you know another working mom yeah Barry
Moy well she made quite the confession
about her five year old daughter all in
my daughter because she looks like her
eyes are giant not a joke my daughter
like it's like this beautiful feminine
version of et and I thought I send
pictures to Steven all the time and I'm
like this was the most easy I see good
at fawning huh oh no you did young drew
instantly became famous from the iconic
movie she forgot to meet Princess died
at the London premiere I know a lot but
I don't know like a lot of grown-up
stuff because I'm not I understand
second grade but as a preteen Drew admit
she became a wild child on the new
Netflix series Norm Macdonald has a show
she opens up about those years where she
went into rehab for drugs and alcohol
before she was even 13 midlife crisis
you know institutionalized blacklisted
no family like got it done and then got
into the cycle of being my own parent I
had a mom but she was more like a best
friend and she was like do you want to
go to school and get bullied all day or
do you want to go to studio 54 I'm like
yes I was much happier at the clubs
she says she turned a life around by age
14 but never finished her education I
dropped out of school um once I got
emancipated the judge says you'd never
have to go back to school but you should
go voluntarily and house like out
[Music]
[Applause]